the report has concluded he has
deliberately misled the house that's not
that much of a surprise because the fact
that he uh decided uh to resign on the
basis of the findings of the report
which he had sight of uh before the
committee uh published it
to all of ours indicates that he
realized that he was going to have a big
sanction and I've got a copy here okay
yeah
absolutely online as well
um it's with pictures
long I'm just going to the conclusions
yeah I tried to scroll down to the
conclusion that the summary
okay here's some uh the committee had
previously concluded it was very likely
that he had uh misled the house and
it says here that the report now
considers that if Mr Johnson was still a
member of the house he should be
suspended from the service of the house
for 90 days
and we have a wow from Jill there
because that is a much bigger sanction
than was suspected in the run-up to this
so as an expectation that perhaps he'd
be recommended to be suspended for more
than 10 days which would trigger a
by-election uh potentially or a recall
petition at least in his constituency
but the recommendation of suspended from
the house for more than 90 days it says
for repeated contempts and for seeking
to undermine the Parliamentary process
we recommend he should not be entitled
to a former members pass this is also
from the committee uh here are some of
the charges deliberately misleading the
house deliberately misleading the
committee breaching confidence in
punching the committee and thereby
undermining the Democratic process of
the house being complicit in the
campaign of abuse and attempted
intimidation of the committee and that
relates to some of the criticisms made
by allies that this was a kangaroo
support Boris Johnson himself saying it
was a political stitch up there was an
expectation perhaps that some individual
MPS would be named in the report uh I
don't know if they have been named in
the report but certainly criticism of
the way that uh the committee has been
undermined by Boris Johnson and some of
his allies accusing it of being a
kangaroo court and he's it says that he
was complicit in that campaign of abuse
and attempted intimidation It also says
we came to the view that some of Mr
Johnson's denials and explanations were
so disingenuous that they were by their
very nature deliberate attempts to
mislead the committee and the house
while others demonstrated deliberation
because of the frequency from which he
closed his mind to the truth in view of
the fact that Mr Johnson is no longer a
member as I said we recommend that he
should not be granted a former member's
pass so they're some of the top line
lines that we you know we're going
through this uh big report as we speak
you can see it there on your screen so
over 100 pages but that sanction K is
much bigger uh than was expected
um and it explains now the Furious uh
resignation of Boris Johnson on Friday
night at about 8 P.M where I haven't
seen the report and having had his
honors list passed uh by Downing Street
and published that he immediately quit
Parliament because he clearly from this
report saw the writing on the wall and
decided that perhaps his career for now
as he puts it was at an end given the
level of that suspension the extent of
that suspension and quit before he was
sanctioned in this way uh by colleagues
Jill I wonder if you could respond to
the point that has just been highlighted
there by Beth in and the final
conclusion of the committee in the light
of Mr Johnson's further contempts we put
on record that if he had not resigned
his seat we would have recommended that
he be suspended from the service of the
house for 90 days for deliberately
misleading the house deliberately
misleading the committee breaching
confidence impuning the committee and
thereby undermining the Democratic
process of the house and being complicit
in the campaign of abuse and attempted
intimidation of the committee they're
throwing the book at him there they are
but I think what we're seeing here is
two things one is the sort of initial
investigation into did he mislead the
house and they've concluded that
remember there was that probing in the
committee when we were watching it about
whether maybe he was Reckless and some
people thought that maybe the committee
would conclude that he just didn't do
enough due diligence having been given
assurance and they've actually decided
no this was deliberately misleading the
house that's why they've gone uh gone
you know it's quite big on penalties but
then what he seems to have managed to do
is so alienate the committee by my both
his own reactions but also the reactions
to lots of people on his behalf you know
basically saying this is an unfair
process anti-democratic process it's a
kangaroo court we saw Jacob Reed smoke
say that directly after Boris Johnson's
evidence uh so the committee seems to be
sort of putting down a further marker
that you know there are actually two
sets of offenses here if you like
there's one about misleading but there's
the second one about not recognizing the
rights if you like a parliament to
assert its standards the Privileges
committee exists basically to protect
the ability of parliament to do its job
to say that you know we will deal with
members who get in the way impede
Parliament ability to do its business
and one of those really important ones
is that ministers you know people can't
come and lie to the house because that
you know undermines a whole basis of
accountability so I think we're as you
say seeing them saying actually we've
got to take a big stand on this and if
you like making exemplary punishment
which is why I think they're gone for 90
days the other thing that they were born
in mind is this is not just some Junior
parliamentary under Secretary of whom
nobody has hurt this is the prime
minister who is doing it also actually
in the report they note of the contempt
of parliament on the June the 9th and
this relates to that explosive Johnson
statement that came on Friday night in
which he basically denounced the
committee said it was a kangaroo
uh Court said that it was a political
stitch up said that he had no other
option uh but to quit because this was a
sham process and they have uh said that
that was a further contempt because he
was effectively publishing information
about uh what the committee had
concluded and that was obviously
privileged and confidential information
so it could be that by his own actions
he has exacerbated if you like his his
uh his sanction